have you had fun ladies and gentlemen
here thank you for Julia believe it or
not we've come to the final segment of
kind of funny on the game spot co-op
stage Tim can you believe it
no not at all yeah it's won by really
quick dick oh my really real good though
I liked it Tim you brought somebody up
which I did this is my friend Dan hi Dan
you brought out the ego
Wow my god oh yeah let's play some more
e let's go right into it everybody oh my
god
yep this oh here yeah we're actually in
a live gameplay demo with our friend
Sarah V on the side you can't see her on
camera but she's playing for us here you
playing games for us all day but yeah
we're just showing off one of the two
stages you've been playing on new dunk
city in the Metro Kingdom kind of dog
game play there all that good stuff I
heard you guys you guys got chance to
play the game also right did get a
chance to play there's a left flight
going up later on youtube.com slash
kinda funny games subscribe like share
ah but I had a lot of fun with it we
played for about 15-20 minutes and I'd
say about seven and a half minutes ish
per level yeah so it was fun my thing is
Mario games are probably my favorite
games of all time
yes if it was a single franchise I would
definitely say that it God is my
favorite franchise now we haven't gotten
a 3d sandbox Mario game in a long time
yes with Mario 64 or Mario Sunshine yeah
and then the galaxy games were fantastic
but they were kind of a weird in-between
where there were a lot more linear than
yes they had that - yeah the devs
actually described it as a miniature
miniature garden which is all I've got
to put out surfing for active it haha
cool new ah okay they turn for a
miniature garden which is what they do
and they very interesting design very
particular how they design it so you can
just go and explore discover everything
in this condense space yeah
can I try to create so what's the
philosophy then for going back to the
other style they just want to I do
something different that using the Hat
the whole thing with Caffey a different
exploration aspects that's what they
want to something different with this
one they've already done galaxy they
want do something different when they
did created this they want to pay
something that people could just really
have fun with and be complete lost at
the same time just be surprised as
they're going through the whole game
like jumping up taxis so looking at the
trailer
it was absolutely bonkers yeah starting
off with that t-rex and all of that like
that where did that type of inspiration
come from the devs actually from what I
got from my r stands like they really
decide one of the person they killed was
the idea of capturing that whole capture
mechanic and then they basically just
asked that anyone come any idea that you
come up with and they had a bunch and
they basically chose their favorites to
create the game so hence the t-rex being
taken over with cap LS something like
that and even the different alley of
different outfits - right now you can
see - by this outfit by the suit - so
something that I noticed when we're
playing the demo is that there's checks
all over the the levels right maybe time
you get the check points you can go to
your map and fast travel to those yes
you can fashion a your map points on the
map yeah how big are the maps compared
to the mario64 maps for example that
that's what kind of comparators the idea
of collecting all those moons like
similar in Super Mario 64 is letting all
those different stars but this one you
see this piece is a little suit oh let's
go he does look good I love it
it's a tie on everything yeah yes but no
that's why they tried they they really
want for that marthy for style just just
have more fun with it how they design
everything the capturing McCain we're
talking about second arrow and they
really had fun with it
awesome so Mario 64 every level had
about six stars that you can collect how
many moons are in each left oh geez
I've seen some so far they had like 30
40 50 plus yeah there's a lot of moons
in them and the moon power the the
Odyssey that's Mario ship to get on King
in the kingdom but yeah the difference -
between Mars you think four is that
every time you got a star you had it you
start level over again yeah this time
you get moons you just keep going okay
so it really does try to get you into
that idea that you can just keep playing
over and over so you can play it like
5-10 minutes to find some moons or you
can sit down for a marathon session and
play forever
but I feel like this is a very lofty
comment to make but seeing this like
seeing the trailer and then playing it
today
it kind of is giving me breath of the
wild vibe yeah firms are reinventing
what Mario is and making it so open and
not getting in your way and want you to
keep exploring si in different things
and like I had such a great time going
around the corners and getting moons and
feeling oh man here's
the one here's another one and it kind
of felt like it just kept wrapping up in
the same way the shrines did you see
well off in the distance you see a moon
even though you're going for another one
you're like wait how do I go in how do I
go see that's actually a big difference
between breadth of the wild and Mara and
shoot and jamario uh Odyssey is that
it's more about that thing you find
right in front of you versus Zelda was
like how do I get to that point way off
of the distance oh that's what they
really do differently in this game well
something that I didn't do a good job of
in the demo I did early and I kept
failing at is one of my favorite things
about mario 64 was that beginning level
like outside the castle yes just going
with the trees and climbing them and
flipping off and just trying to figure
out what I could and couldn't do and
immediately within five minutes of
playing this I was like wait can I climb
that I was like oh I can climb that oh I
can't find that trying to figure out
what the rules are and especially in
udon city like seeing the skyscrapers
it's like oh there's ways to get up
there yes and are waiting it up and
Malana me up Selda in a lot of ways to
just feel there's a lot more verticality
to the levels then there was and say
Mario 64 M hmm that's one they really
built in this one only instead that
whole density that really that sense of
exploration that's inside that areas I
had a lot of fun with that for sure so
the human people yes in New York City
with Pauline you feel mmm how do they
make you feel you happy about night I
think it's pretty cool it's I like
seeing Nora do something new and
different you never seen him before so
this is only and it's only one of the
kingdom this is the Metro Kingdom so you
all use everything you see there's
Pauline hang on the auditorium failure
Pauline yeah we saw it was awful how'd
you notice I love via the Easter eggs
here obviously Pauline from the original
Donkey Kong game another thing we ran
into is our friend captain toad yes hang
out go to this level guys yeah yeah no
you gotta go five cops don't play this
when you find him does he confirm that
captain toad treasure tracker is coming
to the Nintendo which he does it doesn't
tell you anything
he did tell me Eddie no not anything yet
yeah find out I'm so excited to play
this game it's like one of the the best
things for me at e3 is playing a game
and being like all right I don't want to
play this more right now because I can't
wait to just play the entire thing I
just think even though I work it when
even working at Nintendo there's often
times where I will avoid I will only
play what I have to play to talk about
the game but I don't want know anything
else I don't want to
myself so I get laid at home I do feel
like it's an additive experience I'm
just kind of going through and finding
every moon seeing every place you want
to go and then getting there and also I
love that there's a lot more mechanics
going on
yeah then in previous Mario games
especially with the Hat with Kathy that
Kathy changes everything of how this
game works to be able to use the Hat
number ways to capturing all those
things going on so yeah yeah that that
and see what's gonna be like when you
capture the t-rex the goombas the the
moai which we which you have not should
be got a chance to get that for ya man
Kingdom with the sunglasses we didn't
get that if you get far enough in the
eye shape sunglasses that you drop and
then you can see hidden pathways and
yeah wise just interesting so what I I'm
excited about is the gameplay
opportunities that the different Cappy
abilities give you when the level we
played I got to play is Bullet Bill yeah
thanking them you can move around on one
plane you can't go up or down yeah so
it's like that's one like gameplay
element they got but then when you take
control of something else for example it
allows you to like fly of it or like
swim a bit and I'm interested to see
what the dinosaur does and what all
these different things do and it's kind
of like a bunch of minigames within the
obvious like tried-and-true tight
platforming the Mario's know exactly
that's that's part of the fun is choose
discovering what can Kathy control or
not control or capture for that matter
there's some cool things that he can
well we've seen some of that some ways
that's the treasure like the t-rex the
Goomba the the Koopa we gotta start
throwing the frying pan back and forth
um and there's the map actually as well
she just drop a second ago actually not
sure we're Sara's warping us to will
find out things so for my reward of her
favorite part back to the beginning
that's not together it uh so is there a
hub world like is there Peach's castle
or something equivalent we really
haven't talked too much of what the
hopper was gonna be I know a lot of
people been asking that question um
we're not sure yet we haven't really
talked a lot of people are assuming it's
gonna be new dog city but we haven't
really got into that detail yet let's
just wait till October okay
number 27 make it like minigames and
stuff like here yeah alright yeah right
here Mario chiclet threw a cabbage you
took over a person you capture one of
the people nice a chosen
remote-controlled car to try to get
someone of that moon that's hidden over
there or if Sarah can make it
she do it I believe in her do it I
believe huh I believe II here we go
that's it
no almost there there we go he's pretty
stoked about I like those I like them
any games that are hidden or not hidden
but like littered around the world or
you were doing the jump rope one earlier
yeah I totally see that being like we
only had five minutes of a depth we can
record it's like I want to see I would
love to have just done that for a while
I'm like how many Mario jumps can you
two in this jump I've seen people do
I'll actually share herself is actually
done it before using the motorcycle oh
wow she's gotten I gotten a couple of
jumps action on the motorcycle just
jumping up and down and that's something
that definitely want to discover as well
is that they have certain solutions and
they want to see what other solutions
people come up with and they start
trying to solve these problems so what's
going on here cuz this this is good man
galaxy vibes she actually went into the
manhole she moved one of the manholes
with the capture and then action now she
went down into this secret area you
discovered to try to climb more moon
shards off of their moon okay using
using Caffey you're able to then throw
throw copy to actually move the
different pieces and it's cool too you
can throw capping it to actually stun
the Piranha Plants
chance yeah so what's copies deal what's
his backstory
we haven't revealed cab yet be basically
a lots all these things I actually don't
know the full story but have you haven't
discovered yet it's easy to play
ignorant all these things yet so but no
happy is great because it's like it's
like if someone who mario invention with
on this great odyssey a hit so well so
speed of that like jokes aside mario not
necessarily known for story and all that
am but i appreciate in this game there
seems to be a lot of non playable
characters just kind of like adding like
what they have to say yeah but unlike 64
sunshine we're like the toads or the
Delfino island people forgot their names
would be talking to you you have to keep
hitting AI like it through it these are
just kind of prompts that pop up and
don't get in your way and then it's like
it's I felt like there was a lot of
momentum in this game and also the new
role ability I got really loves the
speed does that give a role ability even
the hat storing the Cappy there's always
everything you can do and explore with
CAD which is awesome they have a chance
to do but the story is interesting with
the fact that now it's Bowser's trying
to marry Princess Peach this time they
have a whole wedding outfit about time
instead of them about Talia Mara's got
the outfit too but even beyond results
to do end
the brutal which is that carry that you
see on the airship those kind of bunny
things yeah those are called the brutal
what's their deal
they're basically helping Bowser playing
his wedding mm ugh planners yes I can't
hate all that Oh Oh like Jennifer Lopez
got to do it for love I get it yeah yeah
do what they can
so what's something cool that we can see
here I'm not sure where Sarah can take
us anywhere you want is anywhere you
guys want her to take you guys uh I
don't know go climb something really
high okay good I can get let's get I
look specific top tippy top game just
looks so good - oh it does and the
coolest thing so we get to play this
anywhere if we want like that's the I
know my mind like returns to these fire
games being of this quality but on a
home console but now whoa there we go
I'm really excited to see both later
levels in this game because I loved it
it took all the knots like yeah the
level this new dog cities all this
Donkey Kong s things going on like the
construction and stuff that's super cool
and all the outlets that he wears with
throwbacks to random old Mario things
whether it's Game Boy games like golf or
boxing and all that she and I she who's
gonna talk about with the climbing
situation you can climb up there you
climb up steps little steps right there
kind of climb up there card but I did it
earlier
I see Jerry can man have you jump rope
with a motorcycle no so but I'm sure we
try to set it up well I'm being honest
he's trying we'll see well yeah no
that's not worth as far as object always
hides you can exploring scheme you can
discover up there she goes oh nope she
jumped off hey
lining up there we go oh oh it's okay
it's okay yeah you got as high as you
can
it's fine in that regard but ya know
that's part of the fun I'm just really
just exploring this whole area there's
the oddest you can see off in the
distance
oh cool Oreo ship did you actually get a
chance to go inside the Odyssey no we
did for a second I was paying attention
yeah which then a lot Reggie was next
out arms I got this track yeah we left
out to go buy a sombrero yes cuz I
really wanted to
that's what you do in this game yeah
exactly yesterday there's sombrero the
poncho doll the aesthetics even like the
explorer outfit e hat on as well is it
all aesthetic done so far all showings
better text aesthetics okay okay cool
what you had with it depends where
you're right because like to get some
Mexican part of the poncho and the
sombrero you have to get the purple
coins okay they're called regional coins
that's the name of officially so yeah
and you can use to buy certain ions when
you're over there so what are the
differences between the coins dead
because I'm seeing you have 205 coins
normally a hundred get you alive what's
going on you so probably right now Sarah
use the coins actually to buy a bike to
buy this costume right here that suit
that Mario is wearing so it depends
the coins needs for different things
that discover and right now which is
right now is the actual mission that all
right now is to help that drummer you
just have a band yeah so you're helping
player find the band member I got it
I'll say all that we've come to the end
touch over yeah that's how why our team
are you can have perfect music there you
gotta move that's how we end it uh thank
you so much for coming by thanks right
uh we wanted to tell you of course that
of course I'm sure you knew your games
awesome you're kind of funny improved
III of work oh yeah yeah Odyssey very
well done everybody oh thanks everybody
else you also guilt
when's the coming out October 27th
alright great not too far off
yeah wait anywhere you can play a on the
switch anywhere you're going or plate
lazily like a tomb yeah I played games
pretty lazy now with this guy I'm
interested for all that I do drive it's
all Salvage
what's him thanks for joining me thank
you for having me it's been a pleasure
to hang up ass it's been a pleasure to
hang out with all of you Jeff fun
ladies and gentlemen remember even
though this is the end of kind of funny
on the GameSpot co-op stage they will be
back tomorrow so go to twitch.tv slash
gamesswag gamesswag com all that jazz
you catch us on youtube.com slash kind
of funny games
there's also youtube.com slash kind of
funny we just put up a video of us going
through our sex dungeon Airbnb you heard
that right
go check that out but thank you all for
hanging out today thank you in person
for hanging out today ladies and
gentlemen this is e3 2017 and until next
time it's been our pleasure to serve you
[Applause]